بروس لي".. التنين الصغير
، كيف كانت نهايته؟
وهل مات مقتولا حقا؟
هذا ما سنراه في هذا الفيديو
من قصة أسطورة الكونغفو بروس لي
في الجزء الثاني من قصة بروس لي للقصة بقية
عاش  البطل والممثل الأمريكي ذو الأصول الصينية
حياة قصيرة، لكنه ترك خلفه أثراً كبيراً،
وكأنه كان يدرك أن العمر لا يقاس بعدد السنوات،
وإنما بحجم الإنجاز والعطاء.
وعندما شاهد أحد المنتجين الكبار  بروس لى وهو فى عراك مع أحد الأشخاص،
فأعجب بأدائه وحركاته السريعة، واقترح عليه العمل في السينما،
فرحب التنين الصغير بالفكرة، وخاض أول تجربة سينمائية له
في عام 1971 بفيلم "الرأس الكبير"،
وكانت المفاجأة أن الفيلم حقق نجاحاً كبيراً في عرضه الأول.
ثم أنتج العديد من الأفلام وآخرها كان الأشهر ويدعى ب(لعبة الموت)،
لكن بروس لي توفي قبل أن ينتهي انتاج هذا الفيلم،
فهل عرف البطل أنه سيلعب مع الموت قريبا، فتمت تسمية الفيلم بهذا الاسم..
لكن قبل ذلك فقد تم انتاج فيلم له يدعى  "Enter The Dragon" ،
وبلغت ميزانيته مليون دولا، لكنه حقق أرباح قدرت
ب٢٠٠ مليون دولار،
أرقام مهولة في ذلك الوقت
ويعد هذا الفليم واحد من أفلام لي ذات الميزانيات والأرباح الكثيرة،
نعم هذا البطل في العشرينات من عمره فقط،
وعندما كان طفلا لم يجد نقود ليشتري له حذاء أو ليستبدل قميصه المهترئ،
وأن يأكل شيئا غير كسرة الخبز اليابسة مع الماء،،،
في غضون سنوات قليلة انقلبت حياته رأسا على عقب،
وانتقل من العيش في الثرى، ليعيش في الثريا،،،
وفي ال٢٠ من يوليو ١٩٧٣ توفي بروس لي،
الذي عرف عنه، أنه
يمكن أن يأخذ قطعة نقدية
من راحة يدك قبل أن تتمكن من إغلاقها.
وأن ركلاته كانت سريعة جدًا حيث اضطروا إلى إعادة تصوير مشاهده بالحركة البطيئة.
فضلا أنه كان يعرف راقص ماهر جدا... فكيف مات بروس لي؟...
تقول أول الشائعات أن بروس المُلقب بـ«التنين الصغير»،
تم قتله بواسطة بعض خبراء الكونج فو،
خاصةً أن ابنه براندون تُوفي في نفس الظروف تقريباً
عام 1993، أثناء تصويره أحد أفلامه السينمائية.
أما ثاني الشائعات، فكانت «منتجي هوليود قتلوه بالسم لمشاكل شخصية»،،
وبحسب مصادر كانت شديدة القرب منه،
أنه كان ضحية صراع بين شركات الإنتاج في هوليوود، ومات مسموماً،
حيث تبين وجود انتفاخ في كل أنحاء جسمه، وأثبتت عينات من جسمه وجود أثر للسم.
في حين يرى البعض الآخر،
أن الوفاة طبيعية وتحدث عادةً لممارسي الرياضة الكبار،
لبذلهم مجهود عضلي مضاعف سواء في النازلات أو الأفلام.
لكن وهنا نكمل القصة التي نقلها ابنه وزوجته ليندا وبعض المشاهير،،،
كان بروس في غرفة نوم صديقته بيتي، عندما كان يجلس معها
واشتكى من صداع ولم يستطع الحركة، فارتاح في غرفتها وأعطته مسكن،
وطلب منها الاعتذار لصديقه جيمس كوبرن، عن الموعد المحدد بينهم.
وفي اليوم التالي،
اتصل كوبرون  بها وفوجئ أنه مازال نائماً، فطلب منها أن توقظه فلم يستيقظ،
ثم نقلوه للمستشفى، واكتشفوا أنه توفي قبل وصوله بساعة تقريباً،
إلا أن الدكتور الذي كشف عليه كان أمريكي، وخوفاً من الحكومة
تردد بأن يُعلن خبر وفاته، فأبقى هذا الأمر سراً وبدأت الشكوك وقتها أنه اُغتيل،،،،
فما رأيكم أنتم متابعونا ما هو السبب الحقيقي لموت بروس لي؟
وأيا كان السبب فقد صنع الأسطورة بروس لي ثورة حقيقية
في عالم فنون الدفاع عن النفس،،
ليس هذا فقط بل أنه صار أحد أشهر الممثلين والأبطال  السينمائيين في هوليود،
كل ذلك ولم يتعدى ال٣٣ من عمره.. .